[Music]
if you watch your favorite Disney movie
a few times you'll notice each film has
hidden references to other Disney movies
and characters the princesses are linked
to other storylines which unveiled
hidden secrets in their family trees as
well as some unexpected connections that
will absolutely blow your mind if you're
new to our channel don't forget to
subscribe and please give this video a
big thumbs up
today we'll be sharing 10 Disney
princess connections that will make your
jaw drop just wait until you find out
who Elsa and Anna are related to you'll
be completely shocked Moana and Arielle
the 2016 film Awana was directed by the
same team who worked on the movies
Hercules Aladdin The Princess and the
Frog and the Little Mermaid so it's
really no surprise that this movie had
some pretty obvious ties to a Disney
film and Princess Internet users have
discovered that the movie Moana is the
Little Mermaid in Reverse in Moana the
main character wants to leave her life
on land behind to live out on the scene
and in the Little Mermaid area want the
exact opposite she dreams of finally
leaving the sea behind so that she can
live life out on the land there is
another connection between these two
films that you may not be aware of
Ariel's best friend flounder makes a
brief appearance in Moana that you may
have missed the first time you watch the
film when the character Maui is singing
the hit song you're welcome you can see
a tiny image of flounder swimming in the
sea were you aware of these strange
connections between Moana and Ariel let
us know down below in the comment
section frozen and Tarzan many Disney
fans have speculated that movies frozen
and Tarzan are linked together in a
pretty shocking way those suspicions
were confirmed when frozen's directors
Chris buck and Jennifer Lee gave some
more insight on how these two films are
connected in the movie frozen
it shows Elsa and Anna's parents heading
out to sea to attend a wedding but their
ship appears to capsize and everyone
assumes their parents for lost at sea
but according to the directors Elsa and
Anna's parents didn't perish on the boat
after getting caught up in a terrible
storm the king
of arendelle survived the crashing waves
and horrible weather when their boat
washed up on the shore of a jungle
they took residents in the trees and
even built a tree house but the most
shocking fact of all is that frozen
directors confirmed that the king and
queen had a young son with them before
they both got eaten by a leopard sounds
familiar
Elsa and Anna's brother that brings us
to the next amazing Disney connection on
our list all this time we thought Anna
and Elsa were the only children of the
king and queen of arendelle but that's
just not the case remember when we told
you Elsa and Anna's parents lived life
in a jungle after their boat washed
ashore they had one more child together
a little boy who they raised in a
treehouse they built from the ship's
wreckage according to frozen's directors
when the king and queen were eaten by a
leopard the boy became an orphan that's
when the gorilla caliph Ines the baby
boy in the rune tree house she takes him
back to the jungle and raises him as her
own son and gives him the name Tarzan so
what does this all mean well based on
what the directors of frozen have told
us as well as the correlating scenes in
both movies it's pretty obvious that the
king and queen of arendelle are the
parents of Tarzan which makes Tarzan
Elsa and Anna's brother wouldn't it be
awesome if Disney made a spin-off of
these two movies we definitely think so
Prince Erik and Cinderella
Disney animators have always found a way
to slip in characters and images from
other films into new movies like this
scene from The Princess and the Frog for
example Aladdin's magic carpet is shown
hanging over one of the balconies it may
not hold much significance but it's
pretty cool to see this Aladdin artifact
in a different film if you're still not
convinced the Disney animators love to
intertwine their movies all you have to
do is check out this scene in The Little
Mermaid before Prince Erik can meet with
Ariel he gets hypnotized by Ursula who
has transformed herself into a girl
named to Vanessa
mimicking Ariel's voice Vanessa
convinces Erik she's the one who saved
his life and the two almost get married
in the wedding scene the guests are
briefly shown and guess who was in
attendance it's no other than the king
brand-new from Cinderella who knew these
two were even cordial with Prince Eric
and his family it's just another amazing
way Disney was able to connect two of
their films what do you think the king
and Duke brought Prince Eric and Vanessa
for their wedding gift Tinkerbell and
the Black Cauldron this next connection
is a reminder that Disney animators love
to include berries characters into
multiple films in this scene from the
Black Cauldron Turan princess Eilonwy
and the rest of the gang fall into a
cave a group of fairy children emerge
and start to observe them very closely
the group of fairies known as the fair
folk eventually surrounds the princess
and her crew and help to guide them to
the surface of the cave the fairy start
to flutter all around the screen you can
see all of their beautiful and vibrant
colors and tiny little wings
if you reach down to grab a handful of
popcorn during the scene you would have
missed a very important cameo appearance
within the group of fair folk is one
very special fairy can you spot her oh
there she is
it's none other than everyone's favorite
character Tinkerbell Disney fans were
able to locate and spot the Peter Pan
character on screen right away did you
see Tinker Bell's cameo the first time
you watched the film the Black Cauldron
don't forget to leave a reply for us
down below in the comments section Elsa
and Rapunzel Elsa and Rapunzel come from
two different worlds also resides in
arendelle while Rapunzel lives in the
kingdom of Corona besides their blonde
hair these two couldn't be more
different they both have magical powers
that they use in different ways the
frozen star has the ability to create
fancy ice sculptures using her hands
Rapunzel was born with the magical head
of hair that can heal and reverse the
aging process but despite their
differences it appears that these two
characters have a secret friendship and
a really close bond in this scene from
frozen the doors open up for Elsa's
coronation and Ana heads outside to
greet all of their guests if you look
closely at all of the people who are
hanging around outside you can see a
very special guest was in attendance can
you spot her there she is
it's Rapunzel with her short brown hair
and Eugene from the movie tangle
this just proves that Elsa and Rapunzel
are indeed very good friends Rapunzel
traveled all the way from Corona just to
take part in Elsa's special day wouldn't
it be awesome if Disney created a movie
centered around Elsa and Rapunzel's
unique friendship that would be one
magical movie
Ariel's mom and Captain Hook you
probably never thought there was a link
between the Little Mermaid and Peter Pan
but we're here to let you know that
these two movies have a lot more in
common than you think in the Little
Mermaid Ariel's mother Queen Athena
meets her fate at the hands of a group
of pirates there are some clues that
lead us to believe that the main pirate
behind Athena's tragic end is none other
than Captain Hook in the film Peter Pan
a group of mermaids hang out in the
lagoon and there's one mermaid who has
the same red hair and emerald Pallas
Athena
although the mermaid in this movie isn't
given a name she looks a lot like a
mixture between Athena and Ariel the
resemblance is uncanny this pretty much
confirms that Captain Hook is the
suspect in charge of turning Ariel's
world upside down when her mother is
harmed it's not too unlikely that
Ariel's undersea Wonderland is directly
connected to the lagoon where the
mermaids hang out in the movie Peter Pan
do you agree with this theory let us
know in the comments section Jane Porter
and Belle in the movie Tarzan the
gorilla Turk is making a mess in the cab
and there's a brief scene where you can
see a tea set sitting on a table but
it's not just any old tea set it looks a
lot like Miss Potts and her son chip
from Beauty and the Beast so what does
all of this mean well many Internet
users have put the puzzle pieces
together and they truly believe that
Jane is a descendant of Belle's you're
probably asking yourself how can this be
and we're here to break it all down for
you at the end of Beauty and the Beast
miss Potts reverts to her human form
after the curse was lifted the objects
remained the same even if they didn't
have their human-like abilities but that
doesn't explain how the teapot from
friends ended up in the jungle right
many people have determined that Jane
Porter is actually Belle's
great-great-great granddaughter and she
inherited the teapot from her
this would also explain why Jana has no
problem communicating with Tarzan she
inherited a great gift from Belle who
had a unique and close bond with the
Beast on top of that don't you think
Belle and Jane look a lot alike Belle's
favorite book
speaking of Belle everyone knows this
Disney Princess has an intense love for
reading books the character in the 1991
film Beauty and the Beast is a certified
bookworm and she's definitely a lot
different from all the other people in
her small village when she runs out of
books to read she selects a title from a
bookstore that she has already read
twice Belle is happy to read it again
because she says it's her absolute
favorite after the film Aladdin debuted
in 1992 film goers were able to connect
the dots
they realized that Belle's favorite book
is none other than Aladdin itself when
Belle is describing her favorite book to
the shop owner she describes the film
Aladdin
she says her favorite book includes
daring sword fights magic spells and a
prince in disguise that sounds a lot
like a lot into us she also talks about
a girl who meets her prince charming
this girl is Jasmine of course Belle is
describing Aladdin and princess
Jasmine's relationship perfectly are you
surprised that Belle's favorite book is
Aladdin
Ariel and Hercules we know a lot about
Ariel's family tree thanks to the movie
The Little Mermaid
her parents Queen Athena and King Triton
had seven daughters in total a quater
Audrina
Arista attina Adela Alanna and of course
Arielle but to learn more about the
mermaids extended family we have to go
all the way back to Greek mythology
Ariel's dad King Triton is the son of
Poseidon Poseidon is the ruler of the
ocean and he's also known as the God of
the scene then we have the Disney
character Hercules his dad is named Zeus
who's a sky and thunder God in ancient
Greek mythology now it's time to connect
these two families together in the Greek
religion Poseidon is the brother of Zeus
this makes Hercules and King Triton
first cousins
since Arielle is Triton's daughter she
and Hercules are first cousins once
removed
can you just imagine how awesome their
family reunions must have been when
Hercules was family and Ariel's family
all came together we definitely think
Disney needs to create a movie to focus
on these extended family members we
would love to see the interaction
between them all wouldn't you which of
these Disney Princess connections
absolutely blew your mind let us know
your answer in the comments section if
you enjoyed this video don't forget to
subscribe and please give it a big
thumbs up thanks for watching
[Music]
you